A Neat Suarez is the executive director
of the Machine Intelligence Research
Institute and leads the research program,
Nate as the primary author of
most of Mary's technical agenda,
including the overview document agent
foundations for aligning superintelligence
with human interests and are
the Aai paper or curability Oh,
he's here today to discuss
his work with Mary.
And why thinking about the impact of
Ai, uh, not just your Chromecast is,
is an important idea. So thanks so
much. Take Nay Suarez. Everyone.
Okay.
Hello. Uh, I'll try and
go through this on the,
on the faster end so that we
can have time for Q and. A. Uh,
so as mentioned,
I'm the director of the machine
intelligence research institute.
A very roughly speaking, we're a
group that's thinking in the longterm,
uh,
about artificial intelligence and trying
to make sure that by the time we have a
advanced AI systems,
we also know how to aim them.
I'll say more about what I mean by that.
Uh, throughout the course of the talk, uh,
I, I'm sort of going to assume that
people here know what I mean by artificial
intelligence. That said, it's a fairly
vaguely defined term. There's not a,
there's not one concrete definition,
uh,
but to sort of wave in the direction of
this intelligence concept, I'll say that,
uh, if you look all around us at,
uh, you know, the room we're in,
the technology we're using,
this is not a product of our brown.
This is a product of our brains.
Uh,
the reason that humans are the dominant
animal on the face of the planet is not
because we are faster than bears. Uh, it's
not because we are stronger than bears.
Uh, it's because we are
smarter than bears. And, uh,
over the course of time,
if you look at the largest drivers
of change in technical, uh,
or if you look at the largest
drivers of change in, uh, uh,
human and animal welfare over
the last couple of centuries,
it has been due to technological
and scientific innovation. Uh,
and if we can automate technological
and scientific innovation that has the
potential to change the world,
uh,
on a scale not seen since maybe the
industrial evolution, perhaps earlier. Uh,
so this is, uh, you know, Ai, uh, uh,
artificially intelligent machines that
exceed humans in this sort of general
listening capability are
not coming next year. Uh,
but they probably are coming in our
lifetime. A Ai is now making humans money.
And when something starts
making humans money,
they tend to put a lot of
resources into it. Uh, so there's,
there's lots of brilliant people working
on it, many of them here. And, uh, uh,
I think it's a decent bet that it
comes in their lifetime. Again,
I wouldn't worry about it coming around
the corner, but this does mean that, uh,
it's something we should, we should
think very seriously about. Now,
when people start talking about how
we should think very seriously about
artificial intelligence, they'll often
raise a number of concerns. The ways,
concerns, like, uh, what happens
when the computer becomes conscious?
Uh, the Alaska. Like, will it like
humans? Will it hate humans? Uh,
will it reflect on his goals and decide
that they're silly and then decided that
it should kill us? They'll get
concerned about these sorts of,
these sorts of questions. These are
not the right questions. Uh, the,
there is no,
there is no level of complexity and
a computer program where the computer
program is suddenly imbibed
with a spirit. Uh, there's no,
uh,
there's no amount of code.
You can run in a CPU or the CPU will,
will be inhabited by a ghost and the
ghost will look down at the instructions
and decide whether or not to execute them.
Uh,
the CPU just keeps on
executing the next instruction.
You can of course program something that,
uh, you know, rewrites its own code,
but there's no, there's no ghost
that comes down when the, uh,
there's no ghost that comes down and
questions the goals that you gave it to
unless you program something that is,
you know, reading as goals and uh,
rewriting them on purpose. Um, so the,
the concerns of the questions we should
be asking to quote Stuart Russell,
who's the author of the coauthor
of one of the leading AI textbooks,
which many of you may have read. Uh, the,
the concerns with AI are not about
spooky merchant consciousness.
The concerns with AI are about the
ability to make high quality decisions,
which is exactly the thing we're trying
to do with Ai. So, uh, the concerns,
the sort of double edged sword, not sort
of the spooky questions, but the, uh,
the sort of what if we succeed questions.
So many people when they start talking
about concerns about AI will throw up a
picture of the terminator.
Uh,
I was once quoted in a news article
making fun of people who've put up
terminator pictures in all their articles
about AI next to a terminator picture.
Uh, I learned something
about the media that day. Uh,
I think there's a much better picture.
So this is Mickey Mouse
in the movie Fantasia, uh,
who has very cleverly and chanted a
broom to do his chore of Filling the
Cauldron. Uh, so how
might make you do this?
We can imagine that Mickey does this
by writing a computer program and then
having the berm execute
that computer program, uh,
and is thereby automating his
chores. Very, very clever. Uh,
so what might this program looked like?
Well making,
you might start by writing down some
sort of scoring function or objective
function,
uh,
where in this case the Broman gets one
point if the cauldron is full and zero
points. If the cauldron is
empty, this seems simple enough,
then Micky might write a program
that works as follows. I,
it takes some set of available
actions, uh, and they're,
Mickey writes a program that can take one
of these actions that's input and then
calculate how high the score is expected
to be if the broom takes that action.
So this is a predictor
of, uh, this score, uh,
given that the is taking,
uh,
they give an action and then Mickey can,
write a function that just looks at all
the actions for a certain amount of time,
uh, predicts which ones lead to high
scores and then finds one that leads to a
pretty high score.
The reason this is a sort of Arg Max
here is that we don't need to assume that
the, uh, that the broom is able to
predict every single action. Uh,
it may, there may be some actions
where it can predict the consequences.
There may be some actions that
doesn't have time to think about, uh,
but it's sort of, uh, using,
using some ethernet or another.
Mickey will program it to, uh, uh, uh,
in a given set of time. Look at a bunch of
actions, see which ones it predicts, uh,
will lead to a high score and then
execute the one that leads to the highest
score can find with
the allotted resources.
So this is a pretty simple description
of a program. Uh, you know,
the devil's in the details, uh, writing
this sort of predictor and this sort of,
uh, uh, smart search through action
space is basically the whole field of Ai.
Uh, and you know that that is not
proven easy problem. But conceptually,
this is a simple program. And let's say
that Mickey does this and runs the broom,
uh, seems, seems easy enough.
It seems like it should
work, right? So what happens?
Well,
what happens in Fintech fantasia is this,
the broom starts overflowing the cauldron.
This raises two questions. First,
why did the broom start overflowing
the cauldron? And secondly,
why is there a person standing in
front of you telling you that this is
realistic?
Uh,
so the first difficulty is that the,
the objective function that
Mickey gave this brim is not,
in fact the objective function that
Mickey, uh, we'll sort of intending, uh,
Mickey wanted the culture and full and
didn't want to call it an that part was
right, but Mickey, uh, uh,
sort of didn't want the workshop flooded
the workshop being flooded as far worse
than the workshop being empty.
Uh,
and once you realize that
Micky left that term out,
you realize that there's a bunch of
other terms. Mickey also left out,
for example, flooding the
workshop is funny. Uh,
but it's not funny enough
to justify flooding it. Uh,
and uh, killing someone is way worse. Uh,
you should do something as bad as flooding
the workshop many times over in order
to save a life. Uh, and, and, uh,
we realized when we look at
this that uh, Mickey, the,
the problem was not so much the broom,
you know,
gaining a mind of its
own and define Mickey.
The trouble here is that the brown did
exactly as it what it was programmed to
do all too well and Mickey didn't
understand the consequences of what he was
programming.
The second difficulty is that
Mickey Program, the Berm to uh,
maximize as hard as it could,
the expectation of its score.
What this means is if the broom
currently assesses a subjective,
a 99.9% probability that the cauldron
will be full a and it has all these extra
resources lying around,
then the action that most maximize the
score is the one that uses all those
spare resources to push the probability.
So it's subjective probability that
the bucket is full up to 99.9%.
Uh, once it has very high confidence
that the bucket's full or that the,
that their cauldron's full well, there
might be a leak in the cauldron. It might,
it's sensors might not
be working correctly.
There might be someone trying to
take the water out of the cauldron.
Presumably Mickey wanted the
cauldron full for a reason,
then someone's going to get the water out.
So there's all these,
there's all these small probabilities
that the color is not quite full and you
know, there's nothing else,
uh, you know, the, the,
the sort of default actions of sit around
and do nothing after they called her
and looks pretty full, isn't it
going to make the color any fuller?
So may as well the action that
the action that maximizes, uh,
this score uses the spare resources
that are available to increase the
probability even a tiny bit.
The rum has nothing better to do.
That increases then the score.
So even if even if the remaining resources
can increase the score a tiny bit,
this bro,
we'll put those resources towards eking
out that tiny little bit of probably,
uh, the, we in the, in
the AI alignment business,
we refer to this as an open ended goal.
There's the sort of goal where, uh, it's,
it's resource hungry,
it's effort hungry. Uh,
whenever there are spare
resources lying around,
you might as well repurpose them
in towards the filling your goal.
A contrast this with a task like goal
where uh, there's, there's sort of a,
the goal we had in our heads for filling
the cauldron was much more task task.
Like we sort of wanted to fill
the cultured enough and then stop.
And you could try to do that by putting
in all these terms on the objective
function that are like, uh, uh, you know,
penalizing for too much
resources or something. I,
there are many ways you could
try to do this, but uh, uh, uh,
in essence the,
the question or the difficulty that make
you run into here is that he created an
open ended goal rather than a
task like goal. Uh, and the,
this, making a test like goal is
something of a subtle problem. Uh,
in this example, the original objective
function and looked pretty task like a,
it was bounded. There was no way to get
more and more and more utility. Uh, uh,
uh, like it's not like he got one point
for every bucket of water report and then
there would clearly be a, an incentive
to overfill the color. And it was,
it was founded, uh,
and it was very simple.
You can look at the objective function
and you didn't see any spare terms.
And what made this into
an open ended goal, uh,
was the expected utility maximizing,
taking subjective probabilities
that couldn't go to one, uh, and,
and maximizing the expectation.
Uh,
and there are actually a number of
different ways that a goal that looks, uh,
uh, task like can turn
out to be open ended. Um,
and, uh, one example is that if the,
if the system has lots of sub processes,
some of which are pursuing
these sort of open ended goals,
you might be in trouble,
even if the overarching goal,
uh, is sort of task like,
uh, so the, the standard objection at
this point is a, okay, this is not a,
it's not a thing we need to worry
about a ton. And Ai, like, yeah,
the system might not,
there might be unintended consequences
of the objective function. Uh, and, uh,
and the goal might be more
open ended than we thought,
but we can always sort of pull the plug.
Right? Can we just hit the stop button?
So Mickey tries to this,
uh, and it doesn't work.
Uh, and again, I claim that
this is very realistic, right?
Why is it not working Mickey's case?
It doesn't work because Mickey,
because Mickey's broom has repurposed
lots of spare material, uh,
towards things like making more brooms
that can help make sure that the
cauldron's full, what else
was the resource going to
do? Like the action that,
that maximize this score, uh, put
those spare resources to use. Uh,
also if the broom was clever enough to
know that sometimes Mickey tries to get
water out of the cauldron and Mickey,
you will when make, he realizes, uh,
that the objective function
is not what he wanted.
Attempted to hack me apart with an
ax. Uh, the broom like the, the score,
maximizing a actions in something that's
predicting those aspects of the world,
uh, will, uh, automatically
by default. Uh,
do things like make copies,
resist,
shutdown a, this has an
analog I claim in, uh,
in the real world if we tried to
design sufficiently advanced AI systems
by default, if this
system has a model of, uh,
your ability to shut it down and the
fact, and it has a model of, for example,
so let's say that you build an AI system
that has some objective and models,
the fact that, uh, that you're going
to attempt to shut it down animals,
the fact that this will lead to it not
fulfilling its objective, then by default,
if you haven't done something clever
with your objective function, uh,
it now has an incentive to attempt to
subvert you shutting it down or they're,
I can as a separate problem.
But this is the default incentive.
You have to put in a extra work yourself.
If you want to subvert that as a
incentive. That's not to say you can't,
this is not a, is not a oral
doomed talk. Uh, it's just, uh,
by default if you build a
powerful optimizer and send
it towards an objective,
uh,
and then try to turn it off the,
the first step you built something
that was gonna try to subvert you,
turning it off in the second
step. You are, you've now
made yourself an adversary.
Uh, and if ever you're in a situation
where you think your programming,
if you think you're writing a
computer program to be your adversary,
you should probably stop and write a
different computer program. Uh, so, uh,
as an example of of ways you might
try to try to solve this problem, uh,
here's one way Mickey. You
could go back and try to, uh,
address this shutdown
difficulty with the broom.
He could change the score
function by adding a button.
The button doesn't even really
need to be attached to the room.
You can just have a button on his desk
and you can define a score function, uh,
which says if the button's off,
you have the old score function.
But if the button's on,
uh,
you now get appointed few suspend and
zero points if you don't suspend. Now,
this is assuming that, uh,
we have some way to write a,
uh, an objective function and
that sort of detects suspension,
which is very, uh, very
difficult. Uh, like for example,
if there are loopholes in the
suspension detection mechanism,
then the thing might try to
both technically suspend.
We'll also filling the cauldron to get
both like just to, just to hedge his bets.
Uh, but, but let's
assume way that problem,
let's assume that we have sort of an
airtight suspension detection. Uh,
you could try this utility function.
Now,
does anyone have a guess as to whether
this works and if not work is wrong?
Exactly. Yeah. So, uh, the, uh,
it's filling the cauldron and requires
like getting water, pouring it, uh, uh,
getting water in the buckets, carrying
those books along, way pouring it in.
And that's like a, that's
like a difficult task, right?
The spending is a pretty easy task.
Uh,
so it can either get a point the hard
way or it can convince you that it's
terrible and get a point the easy way.
Uh,
so you have now built a broom that
attempts to scare the shit out of you,
which might be fine. Hopefully,
hopefully it, it, it, uh,
I mean you can't press the
button if you're dead, right?
So it's probably just gonna, you know,
make scary noises. But, uh, this is,
this is sort of indicative of the
problems, not a, it's not trivial,
right? There's a, there's a
default incentive problem if you,
if you set up a thing,
uh,
to optimize objectives that you may
then want to change and, uh, uh,
addressing it is not a trivial
problem. Uh, and this is, we're, we're,
we're right now in this discussion,
surprisingly,
we're pretty close to the state of the
art on this problem. There's maybe a,
there's maybe three more inferential
steps. There's maybe three more, uh, uh,
pieces of research that are
built on this problem. Uh,
one of them I did a couple
of years ago, uh, with, uh,
with, you'd Koski Fallen Stein
and Armstrong, and then, uh,
another was a, was built on
that about a year ago, uh,
which was the big red button paper, uh,
that you probably saw the hype about.
It was actually very small result building
on this, but boy wasn't hyped. Uh,
and that was, um, that was,
you probably saw something about that
that was a collaboration between, uh,
one of our associates who work
in the future of [inaudible]
and, uh, learn after,
so his at deepmind here. Uh, and that's,
that's pushing this problem forward.
But this problem is still more or less
unsolved. Uh, uh, will you, you, you can,
the problem here is sort of,
if you have two utility functions and you
want to combine them in such a way, uh,
that, uh, you, you sort of have
three constraints you want,
you want it to follow the first utility
function before the buttons pushed.
And the second one after
the button's pushed,
you want it to not have incentives to
cause or prevent you from pressing the
button. Uh, Andy wanted to
still have incentives to
propagate that button forward.
If it spins up sub
processes, uh, or if it,
if it spins up subagents
or if it does anything, uh,
that sort of extends beyond
the sort of original program.
You sort of like don't want it to
delete the button as dead code.
It turns out the getting all three of
those at once is still a pretty hard
problem. There's a bit more than this,
but it's still still fairly open.
So the moral of the story here is
that this is the sort of work, uh,
that it sure would be nice if we knew how
to do this before we tried to estimate
to fill cauldrons for us. Otherwise
we will end up like, Mickey,
this is Mickey realizing that he should
have done this research a long time ago.
Uh, so let me now step back. I'm,
I'm doing this talk a bit backwards
cause I think in these sorts when we're
talking about Ai,
I think it's important to get concrete
examples of what the real problems are
before talking with the big picture.
Because when people try to talk
about the big picture, immediately,
they sort of often get lost in,
in philosophical discussions
and ethical discussions. Uh,
so now that we've another, we sort of
grounded our discussion in some, uh,
in some of them problems.
Uh,
let's take a step back and talk about
what it takes to sort of align an AI
system here is a dramatically simplified
pipeline of how you might try to get an
aligned AI system. Uh, you
have some humans who, uh,
who are thinking up the,
the goals and values or the objectives
or whatever that they sort of want the
system to have a,
then they do some attempt to translate
that into an objective function.
This may or may not succeed in Mickey's
case. Uh, it didn't quite succeed. Uh,
then you have the system,
uh, uh, uh, attempt. Uh,
so there's, there's, there's sort of
two subtly different, uh, parts here.
One is you specifying formally, uh, what
you want. And the other is the system.
Like getting that into the system.
So many of the goals that we actually
want are significantly more complicated
than fill a cauldron. Uh, and if you say
something like, well, I want cancer cured,
uh, you might, uh, you might, uh,
this might go wrong if a
cancer was in fact good.
And like that's surprising you.
I don't need to worry too much about that,
but it might also go wrong if you sort
of create a metric for measuring, uh,
amount of cancer reduced where that
metric, if you actually optimize it,
has bad consequences, uh, for example,
something killing cancer patients.
Um, and then there's also the issue of,
uh, of the learning framework. This is,
you might, you might have a, uh, uh, uh,
like in the same way that
it's very difficult to write
a computer program that,
uh, by hand that
recognizes a cat. Uh, it's,
it's sort of much more difficult to
write a computer program that by hand
recognizes a complicated goal.
Uh,
you're almost surely going to going to
have machine learning systems that are,
uh,
attempting to learn the objectives that
you're giving them in some fashion.
That framework also needs to
work. Otherwise, all of the, uh,
all of the right objectives,
function specification in the world
won't get that sort of into this system.
And then the other components
that you sort of need working, uh,
its predictions about what consequences
follow from what actions need to be
pretty accurate. Uh, if it,
if it is a predicting the
opposite of how get an action is,
and it doesn't matter how
good its objectives are, uh,
it's going to keep making things worse.
Uh, and then also needs to be able to,
I mean, these, these two
at the bottom are more, uh,
sort of classic capabilities research,
but it also is still needs to work in
order to, uh, Devin AI that works, um,
and does what you intend. So, uh, most,
most media when it focuses on
these problem focus on one of,
I sort of two of these problems,
uh, one of which is fictitious.
They'll focus on the problem of what if
the wrong person is behind the AI. Uh,
you know,
what if the North Koreans go first or
something and they'll focus on this
problem of like,
what if the AI has natural desires that
cause it to not do the things that we
programmed it to do? I think the
ladders largely fictitious, uh,
the former, uh, I think, you know, the
former is going to be an issue, uh,
uh, someday. But currently we are in a
situation where well intentioned people,
uh,
could not,
like if you handed me a box that was
an extraordinarily powerful function
optimizer,
I could put in a description of some
mathematical function and it would give me
an output that made that function.
Uh,
it would give me an input that made
that functions output really large.
I would not know how to use that to
reliably have a very good impact on the
world if this was,
if this system was powerful enough to
build models of the world where it could,
uh,
figure out the effects of my beliefs
on it's a future actions and so on.
Uh,
so we're currently in a situation where
well intentioned people couldn't do good
things if they tried. Uh, and I think
that when we're in this situation,
sort of from an academic or a scientific
standpoint, you know, our first,
our first objective should
be let's make sure that,
well intention people could do good things
that they tried and then we can sort
of worry about these more
political concerns. Uh,
the politicians that I've spoken to are,
uh, at least the smarter ones are, uh,
are pretty good at figuring out that
this natural desires thing is bunk. Uh,
but they,
uh,
they tend to think that this means they
should focus only on the other thing
that the media is talking
about, which is, uh,
whether or not good humans are
standing closest to the system. Uh,
they also focus on things like,
is this going to cause mass unemployment?
And so on. Which I again, I think are
important issues, but I think, uh,
sort of Pale by comparison
to this possibility of a
industrial revolution style
or larger, uh, change to the
way that society operates. Uh,
so, uh, I think these, I think these
are useful things to think about that,
but just they're not done other
things that, uh, that we do at myriad.
There are other things that I think are
sort of most worth technical attention
at this point. Uh, early science
fiction. You know, another,
another thing that we often talk about
whenever we're talking about AI is Isaac
Asimov's three laws of robotics.
Uh, people, people often ask,
why don't we just do the field
last robotics? Well, okay, a,
they're not formally specified,
right? Like in a, in Isaac Asimov,
they're like built into the positronic
brains, whatever that means. A, B,
if they were fully specified, you sort of
want, want them optimized, right? Like,
don't throw an action. Let humans
come to harm. Like step one,
put all the humans on heroin drips
and underground bunkers, right? Uh,
and then see the books are about
how the laws don't work, right?
Like they're like, hey,
here's these laws. Oh look,
it leads to very interesting
failures, right? If they
worked at one p books, right?
So, you know, I think these
make for interesting stories.
I think they are maybe depressingly
more realistic than I'd like them to be.
I think that often humans don't think for
five minutes about the consequences of
what they're about to do.
But I don't think this is where,
where the real issues lie. I think that
you can, if you do think for five minutes,
realize someone's problems there.
I think that the,
that the real places
to look if you want to,
if you want to address some
of these issues are in, uh,
making sure that the system
can learn the intended values.
The better your value
learning framework is,
the less you need to precisely
specify the right, uh,
the right utility function or
the right objective function.
And the more you can build a system
that sort of figures out, uh,
like builds a good model of you,
figures out what your intentions were,
trash and do those things. Uh, and then
I think it's also very important, uh,
to get the optimization hooked up
correctly. Uh, two of the objectives.
So that, so an instance of this,
this is a sort of abstract one,
but an example of this really quick,
if you look at natural selection,
natural selection is
the only known, uh, uh,
engineering and in scare quotes process,
uh,
that we know of that has ever led to
a generally intelligent artifact. Uh,
it has led to quite a bunch of generally
intelligent artifacts, namely brains.
And, uh, if you look at
natural selection, it's a,
it's a sort of very stupid
hill climbing approach.
So one thing we know from this is that
you can get to general intelligence with
enough brute force and
he'll coming approach. Uh,
and we also see in the case of natural
selection is natural selection.
Optimized brains very,
very hard for genetic fitness.
So the external pressure
on the brain, uh, was,
was selecting brands for
being an agentic fitness.
The internal objectives that humans
internally represent as their goals,
uh, are not genetic fitness.
So we have, we have, uh,
goals that were instrumental for survival,
sort of hardwired into our brains.
We have like hunger instincts and we
have a survival instincts. And, uh,
and then we explicitly
represent his goals.
Things like love and justice and
beauty and mercy and you know,
fun times and, and all
this, all this stuff that,
that correlated with survival and
fitness in the ancestral Savannah.
Uh,
but it was things that correlated in the
past with what we were being selected
for. Uh, that that sort
of became our, uh, uh,
the things that we internally optimize
for. Right. So this was a case where the,
uh, the external optimization
pressure on the artifact, uh,
resulted in a generally intelligent
artifact with internal objectives that did
not match to the external
selection pressure. Hopefully
that all made sense. Uh,
similarly, if you are, uh,
uh, applying gradient descent,
uh, to a black box trying to get it to
be very good at maximizing come objective
eye. If you are, if you are
doing this blindly enough,
you might get something very much
like what natural selection got,
which was a generally intelligent
artifact that does pretty well,
but it's actual goals are things that
correlated in the test environment with
your objective and which will not
sort of continue to correlate with the
objective when it undergoes a context
change, uh, or gets more resources or a,
or a different setting. Uh,
so, so I think one of the,
one of the real important things to do
in this work is make sure that whatever
methods we're using for optimizing
whatever objectives are given,
hopefully something like a, like
a value learning framework, uh,
that the internal targets the system's
optimizing for are the same sorts of
things that we are externally selecting
the system for using something like
gradient descent. Abstract point.
I'll, uh, I'll move on now.
Uh,
the,
the take home message here is that we
expect that these things are going to be a
technically difficult.
Uh,
and if we, if we can't get
these things right, it's hard.
It doesn't matter who's
standing closest, right? Uh,
good intentions are not sneezed
on to computer programs, uh,
by the intentions of the person,
like a nice person standing nearby does
not make the program act better. Uh,
if you want the program
back to certain way,
you've got a program at tech that way.
So let's take one more step back.
I sat in the last slide that we're
expecting these things to be somewhat
difficult.
So I'm now going to spend the remainder
of the talk saying why we expect these
things to be somewhat difficult.
First,
I'm going to give a four key propositions
that mean we should care and then I'm
going to go in defending
that. Uh, it's all,
it's not going to be a trivial problem.
So the first proposition is what's
known as the orthogonality thesis. Uh,
this was put forth by Nick
Bostrom. Uh, I think Steve,
I'm a hunter Rowe also had had,
uh, uh, a lot of influence on this.
Uh, more so in the next,
on the next point. But, uh,
this basically says that you can in
theory build an AI system to pursue almost
any goal.
I think most programmers sort of
intuitively intuitively understand this.
There's many people who are
non programmers who say, well,
you couldn't program something
to just fill a cauldron.
Cause when it gets smart enough it'll
decide to fill in the cauldron's dumb and
go do something else. Right? You could
program something that, you know, uh,
once it passes a certain
resource specialed, uh, checks
whether or not it thinks,
uh, filling the cauldron is
dumb and then acts accordingly.
But you could also program something
that just always executes the action that
it predicts leads to the highest score,
where the score is the cauldron fullness.
Uh,
so,
so this proposition
says you can in theory,
build an AI to pursue almost any
objective. The next proposition,
instrumental convergence says that
most objectives imply subgoals such as
survival, acquisition of
resources, and so on. By default,
if you build something that's executing
actions to optimize some objective,
it will, uh, have incentives to try
and prevent it from being itself,
from being shut down because it's the
thing that's leading to the objective
being fulfilled.
It by default has to get more resources.
If those resources better
helping a few of the goal. Uh,
the intuition here is that if you program
a robot to go buy you some milk and
there are two paths, one of which is
dangerous and one of which is safe. Uh,
and it's only objective,
it's scored on whether or not
it gets back to you with milk.
That's the only thing
you're scoring it on,
then it will automatically
take the safe path.
There's not because it has a Annamalai
and fear of the person on the dangerous
path. There's not because
it feels like you do. Uh,
the danger of a gun is cause you
can't get milk if you're dead. Right.
So if it is capable of modeling that
one path is safer and the other path is
more dangerous than, uh, by having
an attempt to optimize and objective,
you sort of naturally get these
instrumental instrumental subgoals. Uh,
these, these follow naturally is called
the instrumental convergence thesis. Uh,
because,
uh,
these are instrumental goals and almost
all objectives converge on these goals
unless you do work to make them not
conversion of these goals. Third Point,
capability gain,
uh,
are potential ways for these systems
to gain greatly cognitive power of
strategic options. Uh,
there's, there's a lot of the,
there's a lot of ways that
this could be true. Uh,
one of the reasons that I think there's
proposition is true is because highly
destructive.
Uh,
but an example of a way for an AI group
to have a rapid gaining capability.
Their system is there some startup
that has very promising, uh,
AI techniques and then Google buys them
and throws a boatload of a GPU is at
them and invents tps for
them. Um, all hypothetical,
I assure you, uh, uh,
another way you could get rapid capability
gain. Uh, uh, so if the system is,
you know,
for the first time getting onto the
internet to where it hadn't been allowed
massive Internet access before, uh,
other ways get rapid capability gain.
If the system is a lot to do hardware
design and is able to find Harvard designs
that are much better than
a human hardware designs,
this is Jim's able to optimize
its own code in some way that, uh,
if it, if it gets better at things like
computer programming than humans, then it,
and you could get, you know, the
Apocryphal recursive feedback loop. Uh,
so there's all sorts of ways that,
uh,
we can sort of imagine a AI systems
getting dramatically more capable than
humans.
I mean,
it could also just be that humans aren't
very high up on the intelligence food
chain and that early AI systems
are as naturally, uh, you know,
in the same way that when humans started
beading or when computers started
beating humans at chess.
What's the statistic?
I think it's something like a 1996 was
the first time a computer beat human at
chess and like 2002 or something was the
last time that a human being a computer
at chess. Uh, I, I, there's probably
not quite right, but it's, it's,
uh,
the window is fairly small,
so you could just expect that a human's
aren't great and it's whole intelligence
thing. Uh, this whole
like laziness thing and,
and needing to eat three
times a day thing. Uh, brains
are very calorie intensive.
Uh,
it could be that the human brain is
optimized for very different sort of thing
then what we would optimize brands for
in the same way that an airplane, uh,
cannot heal his injuries
nor make baby airplanes.
But it can fly a lot further
and faster than a bird. Uh,
it might be the case that early AI
systems lack certain human capabilities,
barriers dramatically beyond a human
capabilities in the axes that matter.
And in fact, we already see
something kind of like this today.
And then the fourth point is that
AI alignment is pretty difficult,
which I'll argue in the remainder of
the talk. Uh, but before I go there,
take a moment to, uh, to think
about these three propositions. Uh,
if you believe these three propositions,
uh,
the first one says it's possible to
build AI systems that are utterly
indifferent to, uh, to human
objectives. The second one says that,
uh,
those systems by default will be in
competition with humans for resources.
Uh, and the third one says that, uh,
they're gonna, they're gonna win.
Uh, so if these three are, if
these two propositions are true,
then this means that we had better
not screw it up. It doesn't mean that,
you know,
it doesn't mean that we're screwed.
It just means that we
could be screwed if we, uh,
if we deal with the situation poorly,
right?
So if you believed all
those three propositions,
that means that this is really important
to get right. Uh, if we get it wrong,
it could go very poorly. And of
course, it goes without saying,
almost I'll say in any way that if we
get it right, I had, could go super well.
Uh, the, the whole point that we're doing
AI research is because, uh, you know,
the greatest drivers of improvements
in welfare have been technological and
scientific. And if you
can automate those, uh,
you can go a lot faster
than we going today. Uh, so,
so there's great potential for upside.
Uh,
and if you believe these three
propositions, then there's also, you know,
there's a really important
thing to get right. Uh,
if in fact this fourth point stands,
which are argue shortly,
that means that we need to start
seriously focus focusing on these sorts of
problems.
So without further ado,
why do I think that element is
somewhat difficult? Uh, I mean,
the real reason is that I worked on
the problems are a fair bit and uh,
they seem difficult to me, but, uh,
also draw some analogies
and also encourage you to
look at some of the problems
and try them yourself. Uh, we could
use more people working on these. Uh,
one of the reasons to expect that,
uh, uh, AI alignment is difficult,
especially when you're looking at these
really advanced systems is for the same
reason.
You should sort of expect a priori that
rocket a rocket engineering is more
difficult than airplane engineering.
Uh, when you're first designing rockets,
you might argue, oh, well the rockets are
going to these basically just airplanes,
right? Like, uh,
it's all just like material science
and aerodynamics at the end of the day.
Right? Like, what, like how
our rockets, how could they,
how could they end up being like more
difficult to get right than airplanes?
Well,
the reason the Rockies are more difficult
to get right than airplanes is that
they undergo a extreme stresses,
extreme context changes,
and they're pack chock full of
explosives. Uh, I argue that, uh,
that there's a very similar analogy to
when you're, when you're trying to build,
uh, an AI system. There's a,
there's a difference when you're trying
to build an AI system that's going to
drive a car versus when you're trying
to build an AI system that's intended to
go beyond the human regime in general
intelligence, whatever that means.
Uh, and in the, in the first case,
you know, it's safety critical.
It's very important. You've got to,
you've got to get the job right.
In the second case, uh, you're going
somewhere sort of fundamentally new.
You're, you're pushing beyond
the human region. Uh, you are,
you are building something that
if it is, uh, a adversarial,
you're going to have a
bad day. Uh, and you, uh,
you're building something that, you know,
it's not going to start out brilliant,
but it's going to be building models
of the world, uh, where you know,
at some point it's going to realize that
you have beliefs and that your beliefs
affect, uh, w its ability to achieve
its goals. And at that point,
uh, it's outputs will be in part
chosen to affect your beliefs,
right? So you are now, you know, working
with a system that if you built it wrong,
has an active incentive to
deceive you. Uh, you're, uh,
so, so you're sort of, uh,
potentially putting the system under,
uh, uh, much more stress,
under much more ability to, to,
uh,
it's much more likely to undergo a big
context change where it dramatically, uh,
models of the world in different way.
Or if you give it a lot more resources
than it used to have and uh, uh,
and it could go real wrong if you,
if you do it wrong,
this is not too unlike rockets.
Uh, in the same way that a priori,
you should go into rocket design
more cautious than airplane design.
I recommend going into AI alignment much
more cautiously, uh, for the advanced,
for the,
for the sort of long term AI alignment.
I recommend going in much
more cautiously than in, uh,
dealing with narrow systems where I think
many of these concerns I don't really
apply. Second reason, uh,
if you look at sort of
interesting engineering practices,
some of the most entertaining interesting
engineering practices are at NASA
where they do things like
take three independent teams,
give each of the three teams a
different engineering spec or sorry,
the same engineering spec and tell
him to design the same system.
And then they actually
implement the system by taking
all three of those systems
using a majority vote, uh, with the idea
that each of the systems will have bugs,
but hopefully they won't. All three have
a bug in the same place. Uh, this is,
uh, significantly more caution, uh,
going into the deployment of things like
space probes and space shuttles then
goes into the deployment of,
uh, say the new hangouts, uh,
no offense, uh, and,
and the,
you know,
we can ask why is it that space probes
get so much more engineering attention?
Uh, and I think there's a, there's
a bunch of reasons, but, uh, uh,
I think some of the reasons are historical
and I think some of the reasons, uh,
or maybe not quite what you'd expect at a
first glance, you might say, okay, well,
space probes cost a real lot of money.
I think that's part of it.
But I think that, uh, uh, if
you look at big tech companies,
uh, many of their
deployments are also, uh,
two systems that move much more money
than a space probe costs over the course
of a year. Why is it that it's,
it's sort of much less, uh,
uh, it takes much less caution to, uh,
deploy a new feature on a web
app than a space probe? Well,
one of the reasons I claim is that,
uh, the space probe goes to space.
Uh, it's, it's sort of very, it's,
it's much easier to be a cavalier about
your deployments when you can roll them
back easily. Uh, with a space probe,
you can correct bugs if the antenna
works and the receiver works,
you know,
whatever codes during the receiving and
whatever code's doing the decoding of
the message you sent and whatever it
goes, applying the patch, right? Uh,
but the code that runs the receiver
decodes the message and applies the patch.
If that doesn't work, your
space probe is dead. It's gone.
You can't go fix it.
Uh,
in a very similar fashion with
highly advanced AI systems. Uh,
if they start going wrong,
you'll be fine.
If the code that, uh, uh,
make sure you go find it,
make sure that the
system, you know, uh, uh,
assist you in correcting it
works on the first try, right?
But if you build a system that's
sufficiently capable that it could, uh,
do bad things, then, uh,
then the code,
like you'll only,
you'll only be okay in this scenario a
if either the code that works entirely
correctly on the first try or the, uh, uh,
the code that helps you correct errors
works entirely correctly on the first try,
right? So you need the whole system
to work well on the first try,
but you need a component to work on
the first try and getting any code that
works like exactly correctly
in the first deploy. Uh, this,
if nothing I've said yet has sent
fear through your heart, this,
this should I.
And then the third,
the third reason to sort of expect that
this is a, uh, somewhat difficult task.
It's difficult in part for
the same reasons that computer
security is difficult.
Uh, now if you've done your job right, you
sort of, as I said before, you, you, you,
you really, I really recommend against
a designing a computer program,
the expected both to be smarter than
you and adversarial towards you. Uh,
if you're writing that program,
I suggest that you reconsider your
choices and write a different program.
Uh, so ideally you sort of never want to
be in an adversarial situation against,
against anything that you're writing.
Uh,
but there is a sense in which the same
sorts of things that make computer
security difficult make
a AI alignment difficult.
Uh, and so what makes it
computer security so difficult?
What makes computer security so
difficult is intelligent adversaries. Uh,
so in computer security,
if you have a,
you might have a dozen different
vulnerabilities in your code,
none of which is itself fatal, none of
which is itself a easy to recognize.
Uh,
and you might have a very intelligent
attacker who can find all 12 and chain
them together in a really weird and
confusing way to cause like an edge case
scenario, which are less them a break
into your system or just make your system.
Uh, even if you're not dealing
with adversarial systems,
when you're dealing with a highly
advanced artificial intelligence,
you are still dealing with
this, uh, intelligent search.
The search space, you're much more
likely to end up in the edge cases. Uh,
so as a example, there's a very
interesting paper by burden Lasalle,
I think 2007,
uh,
or they attempted to use a very
simple genetic algorithm to evolve a,
uh, an oscillating circuit. And
they did and it worked. And, uh,
they were astonished by the, uh, uh,
very small size of the resulting program
and they were astonished also that it
did not use the capacitor on the
chip. And there were like, well,
how is it making an oscillating signal?
Uh,
so they went in and spent a while
figuring out what this, uh, uh, uh,
evolved program, uh, was doing. And it,
what was doing as it happens was
repurposing the circuit tracks on the
motherboard as a radio to replay the
oscillating signal from the test device
back to the test device. Uh, this is,
uh, and this was not a very smart
program, right? This is just, you know,
use hill climbing on a, on a pretty
small solution space. And the, the, uh,
the solution that it found was sort of
outside the space of solutions to the
programmers were themselves visualizing,
right? There are visualizing things.
They use the capacitor and,
and uh,
and used a programming the way we would
think of programming when the thing
actually used,
uh,
features of the hardware properties of
the hardware that they wouldn't have
modeled in say computer simulation
in a computer simulation.
This thing might've done more
like what they intended. Uh,
but the actual solution space in the real
world when they ran the code was wider
than the one that they were visualizing.
It. Even this fairly stupid, uh,
optimization algorithm found a solution
that was outside the space that are
visualizing a, in the case of
an intelligence system that, uh,
that's significantly smarter
than humans on certain axes,
on whatever axes you're measuring a
significant better at humans say that
predicting consequences of actions or
it finding actions that lead to certain
outcomes.
Uh,
you should by default expect it to be
pushing towards these sort of weird
situations.
If there are weird hacks,
if there are weird edge cases that let
it get a dramatically higher score, uh,
you're just expected to
find those, right? So, uh,
if it's playing Atari Games and it
eventually realizes that there's a, uh,
a certain series of moves
that Mario can make, uh,
that led it a rewrite the code of Mario
such that it can make it score really
high. Uh, you should expect
performance of the system to sort of,
uh,
as measured by whether or not it plays
of the game super well to go up and then
go down when it gains a, this insight and
the ability to actually rewrite Mario.
Mario is in fact a Turing complete.
There are in fact a series of jumps you
can do, uh, to inject your own code. Um,
uh, I think someone wrote
flappy bird in Mario. It's
really wish that person was doing
AI alignment work instead. But,
uh,
you should expect these sorts of things
you should expect when you're building
something intelligent, you should
expect it to find the edge cases.
You're sort of building something like
the whole purpose of intelligence is
defined clever ways to solve problems and
we can find solutions that we couldn't
ourselves pick out of the
solution space. Uh, and, uh,
the only difference between
a solution that, uh,
is very clever and you can plug into
the source solution space the humans can
see versus a,
a solution that is extremely perverse
and that we really didn't want a,
that was obviously not what we
intended by the objective function. Uh,
the only difference between these
is sort of our feelings, right?
From the perspective of a system that is
trying to optimize score. Uh, you know,
an action that leads to a
high score as an action,
at least Ohi scores and
leads to a high score.
Unless you get a good value learning
framework that is predicting how you would
feel about it.
And then you've got to make sure it's
not trying to affect how you feel about
actions. It could make you really like
the easy actions. And then, uh, anyway,
uh,
so for the same reason that a
computer security gets way harder,
when you have intelligent adversaries
trying to chain together, uh,
lots of weaknesses, you
should expect, uh, uh,
advanced AI systems to, uh, pick out,
uh, to push the weird reasons to the
search space. And this means that, um,
uh, it's not just the,
your, you know, sort of,
it sort of much easier to make code that
works well on the path that you were
visualizing.
And then to make code that works
well on all the past that you weren't
visualizing.
And with AI alignment,
it's going to be using all the
paths you were visualizing. So,
uh, uh, uh, uh, gut intuitive
reason to think of this role.
It might be hard when you haven't
yourselves worked on the problems, uh,
is treat it like a secure rocket probe.
Uh,
so take the problem seriously. Don't
expect the problem to be easy, uh,
and, uh, start thinking about it
sooner rather than later. And also,
I think it was very important,
uh, in this, in this line of work,
it's important to sort of
formalize your ideas. Uh,
such that others can critique
them, uh, and build upon them.
So in this example with the shutdown
button, uh, it's one thing to be like, ah,
we can probably make it so that,
you know,
if we have less that we can
make it shut down correctly. Uh,
and once someone actually writes down
how they would combine the sort of normal
operation utility function when the
shutdown operation until the function, uh,
you can see that it will
either have incentives to
cause you to press the button,
have incentives to defend the button
against you, uh, and so on and so forth.
But if people aren't writing
down their actual ideas,
if they sort of aren't treating them
like math problems or cs problems or
technical problems,
then you get lost in the philosophical
discussions and people arguing about what
they could or couldn't do.
Uh,
rather than actually building the thing
in such a way that if it's wrong, uh,
the person who made it can be convinced
that it's wrong because it's actually
math and you can check, uh, and such
that if it's right, we can build on it.
So this is a, this is super important
and I encourage all of you, uh,
if you're interested in these problems,
uh, to do some of this work. Uh,
so that's all that I
have. I will say that, uh,
there are ample resources
online for figuring out what
some of the open problems
are.
Uh,
there's actually a great paper that came
out of a Google brain called concrete
problems in AI safety that has
I think eight open problems, uh,
that are concrete as the title says
that you can try your hand at a,
there were also, uh, some, uh,
some other sets of problems you can find
on intelligence.org, which is where, uh,
uh, machine intelligence research
institute host their website.
And I encourage anyone who's interested
to look at these problems and help us
make progress. Uh, because as I said,
I think this is real important and I
think we shouldn't defer thinking about it
until later.
That's all.
[inaudible]
thanks Nate. We're going to move
into the questions from the audience.
An alternative to the tiering test that
was proposed by Ben [inaudible] at one
point was send a robot to college.
If it comes back with a decree.
It's intelligent and I liked this problem
because it illustrates a particular
interesting case of utility functions.
It's impractical to gather enough
training data to train that robot on the
explicit utility function.
It would take millions of instances
of sending it to college. Also,
you can't simulate training
data because going to college,
you're surrounded by other capable
students simulating those students would
require solving the problem
you're training for.
Has Miri done any investigations into
how to train systems where the ultimate
utility function cannot be hill
climbed against for either practical or
logically possible reasons?
Uh, so there's a bunch of pizza. Did
that first I'll say, uh, you know,
I think if the actual objective
function is get a degree from college,
he'll do it in much faster than
four years and without, uh,
sitting around other capable students,
I think that I could get a
degree from a college, uh,
faster than that. I guess it depends how
you're, what system's capabilities are.
Uh,
uh,
in terms of utility functions
that sort of don't have a,
these perverse instantiation is,
I would say that a defining one
of those is a large sheriff.
The problem, uh, now I will say that, uh,
I think many people think that
the problem is all about, uh,
how did you get the objective
function just right.
And I think that that's actually
much less of the problem. Uh,
I think that building something
that models your intentions
and tries to extract,
uh,
what type of action it's going to do
by modeling your preferences somehow,
uh, is a much more, uh,
likely to work approach in the same way
that training a cla a cat classifier is
a much more workable approach than trying
to write by hand the cat recognizing
program. Uh, so I'm not, I'm
not very optimistic about the,
let's try and write down utility
functions by hand, a approach.
And I also think that the
problem is in fact more about,
uh, getting the internal targets
of the system to match the,
so it was externally selected for,
uh,
which I need a better name for this
general class of problem. Uh, but, uh,
I mentioned earlier, uh, humans, uh,
humans not internally valuing
genetic fitness as their
top and only priority, uh,
despite being selected only for
genetic fitness. Uh, uh, so,
so I would say that getting utility
function right now, the whole problem,
but maybe a fifth of the problem or
something. Um, in terms of that fifth,
uh, I'm not super optimistic
about, uh, for example,
the college, a utility
function. And I would say, uh,
finding objectives that cannot
be a hill climbed against,
you know, I haven't found, I haven't
found any good things in this direction.
I would say that the thing
to look at is less, uh, uh,
unhackable utility functions and more
something like, can we make it task based,
limited, uh, uh, limited. It's, uh,
yeah, there's, there's, some of these are
discussed in the concrete problems paper.
Uh,
so I take a look there.
What are your thoughts on using formal
verification methods in approaching this
problem?
Well,
verification,
I sort of wouldn't bet on getting very
much in the way of formal verification of
an advanced AI system.
Uh, uh, you know, if you,
if you talk to a program Verification
Community folks today and you say,
Hey, we're going to let the
code alter the code, uh,
they will either shut her or yell at
you to get out of their office. Uh,
more or less, that's not quite true.
Uh, we have, uh, so out of Mary,
we do have some work
that, um, we have, uh,
we have a paper showing how,
uh,
you can write a secure colonel,
that can replace any component of the
kernel, including the verifier component,
uh, which is very hard to do,
um, for a go deleon reasons. A,
you want the old verify or to
verify the new verifier, uh,
and as easy to do if you
have loss of strength,
but it's very hard to do if you don't
have a loss of strength because you'd run
into, into a verifier
consistency, uh, issues. Uh,
so we have a way to do
this with, with, uh,
more or less no loss of strength,
which is very surprising. Um,
that paper is called a hall and hall. It
uses the higher order logic, a theorem.
Prover. Uh, so, so we have
done some thinking about this.
Um,
uh,
I would say that I think figuring out
how you would go about doing this sort of
program verification can be helpful.
Uh,
but it's mostly helpful
conceptually to understand,
uh,
like what sorts of things
you can and can't do. Uh,
and I wouldn't expect early
AI systems to have properties.
You can usually verify.
I think best case you can get
statistical guarantees a something like,
you know,
with probability one given enough time,
this part of the network will converge
on the best policy or something.
Uh, and I think that best case, you also
might be able to get something like, uh,
you know, assuming that these
components work like this,
then this component will work
fine. But by and large, uh, I'm,
I'm pessimistic about ability to verify
large components were fully general AI.
Okay.
Oh, dude. Question from the
door. How the partnership on AI,
recently founded by Google and other
big machine learning companies,
has that has a set of tenants that emit
any mention of the existential risks
that Asi, is this a case of divide
and conquer, Miri covers Ai,
Asi risk partnership covers other issues
or a matter of disagreement about the
risks?
I suspect that it's none of the
above. I suspect that it's, uh,
for political reasons.
Um,
uh,
I'd say I,
I'd say please don't trust Mary to
handle the superintelligence risks all on
their own. Uh, there is,
I think half a dozen or so full
time researchers at the moment. Uh,
those aren't, those
aren't very good odds. Um,
I also, uh, you know,
I don't wanna,
I don't wanna say too much about this
partnership without talking to the people
running it.
Um,
but I'll say that I know they are
consulting with people in the AI alignment
community.
Uh,
and many of the groups
involved in it are quite aware,
aware of the problems. Uh, so I suspect
that insofar as it's not in the charter,
this is a largely political,
and I think also largely, uh,
many of the things that this particular
partnership we'll be looking at are
related to things like make the cars
not kill people, make sure that the, uh,
that the displace jobs
don't, you know, destroy, uh,
lives, uh, or that insofar
as they destroy lives,
those slides are made better in
some other way. Uh, we do, I think,
I think these are important issues,
but again,
I think they sort of Pale
by comparison to these, uh,
questions about the transformative
possibility of highly advanced AI systems.
How does Miri plan to deal with the agr
research groups that keep large parts of
their work secret such
as deep mind and possibly other unknown
groups and say Russia or China? Um,
so I don't know.
I'm also not sure I like this
whole deal with terminology. Again,
please don't leave the whole
problem to us. We're still,
we're still only about
half a dozen researchers.
We haven't grown in the last
two minutes. Um, I'll ask, uh,
I would say, uh, that the,
the type of work that we're trying to
do is sort of the type of work where,
uh,
at the end of the day you fundamentally
understand how to do AI lineman better.
What do I mean by this? Uh, um,
so let's say,
let's say that you're trying to make a
program that plays chess well enough to
be the human, uh, and you
know, the chess program, uh,
uh, it makes some good moves and make some
bad moves you and you tried to like by
hand to patch the bad moves and then
someone comes to you and they say, well,
do you know how to play chess? If I had
to a sufficiently large computer, uh,
you can name how large you
want the computer to be and
I'll give you a computer
that size. Could you play chess in
that case? Uh, if the answer is no.
So the answer today is clearly yes. You
run, you make the whole search tree,
you backtrack. Uh, you know, you see
whether white has a winning move.
You then repurpose the computer to get
all of the bitcoin is a good time. Um,
but uh, uh, if the answer is no,
if you don't know how to do it,
even if I give you an arbitrary
large computer, then you're,
you're fundamentally confused about chess.
Somehow.
You're either missing the search tree
data structure or you're missing the
backtracking algorithm or you're missing
some understanding of how chess works.
Uh, there's actually a fun,
a fun historical read. Uh,
you can read a essay by Edgar Allen Poe,
uh,
on the Mechanical Turk where I'd growl
and Poe that mechanical Turk was a
purported chess playing the
automaton in the 18 hundreds.
Edgar Allen Poe called bullshit.
He was like,
the Mechanical Turk is not a test playing
automaton. I was a stage magician.
I know where the Midget's hiding.
I can show you.
But first let me argue
that it is fundamentally
impossible for an Automaton to
play chess. And then he gives an
argument that's remarkably sophisticated.
There is fundamentally impossible for
an Automaton to play chess. He says,
some people are talking about the machine
and Mr Babbage and they say it can do
arithmetical facts could in
theory do chess. And I argue no,
because arithmetical
questions are deterministic.
Each step folds from the previous,
but chess is not deterministic.
Your opponent's move, uh, it does
not follow from your move. So the,
the mechanistic wheels and gears cannot
represent your opponent's move. Uh,
so the Automaton, uh, can't play chess.
And uh, this is, this is
remarkably sophisticated. A,
he knew about computers. B, he identified
the heartbeat of chess, which is like,
Holy Shit. How do you deal with all
of the opponents possibilities, right?
It does indeed why chess is
right, but he, he, he, uh,
he went wrong. It's sort of like the
last step and you know, then in 1950,
a Claude Shannon is like,
okay,
so how are we gonna make this
computers play chess? Clearly,
if you gave me a computer as large as,
you know, much bigger than the universe,
I could make the tree do the backtracking.
We'd be playing chess.
But like in practice,
that's going to be difficult.
So we need the evaluation functions,
right?
Something changed between
Edgar Allan Poe and Shannon.
What change was whether or not we were
fundamentally confused about what sort of
thing trusses or whether or not we
were fundamentally confused about what
computers can do.
Uh,
uh,
right now we're in the state where no
matter how large a computer you had me,
I could not make a, uh, a
highly capable AI system that,
uh, does even a very simple task like
turn literally the entire universe in the
diamond,
right?
We don't need to worry about any of the
open ended gold problems cause we're
trying to optimize an opened ended goal.
We don't need to worry about these. Like,
uh, uh, how do you reason
given computing resources,
limitations problems because we
can just assume those way, right?
Even if you gave me all the brute
force in the world in a simple goal,
we still don't really know
how to align an AI system.
This is a roundabout way
of saying, uh, that, uh,
that
the type of work that we're trying to
do is the type of work that went in
between Edgar Allan
Poe and Claude Shannon.
I've sort of getting some of
the fundamental algorithms them,
some of the fundamental ways to
think about it such that, uh,
you sort of don't make very clever,
very good sounding,
very sophisticated arguments there turned
out to be wrong for some subtle reason.
Uh, you instead just know
how you would do it if you,
if the problem were simpler in some way.
Uh,
we're one way to simplify it is
to assume you have a simpler goal.
One way to simplify as assume you
have lots of computing resources.
There are many other simplifications you
could do. A, and I would say that, uh, uh,
getting back to the actual
question, I, uh, the,
the idea here is to get these insights,
get a
hi to the AI researchers to the point
where they would sort of automatically
know how to align a system, uh,
with the intended objectives. Uh,
if there weren't practical limitations
and then be figuring out how to do it if
there were practical limitations.
Cause there are a,
and I would say in the sense we don't,
we don't really,
we're not really trying to deal with,
uh, people keeping their stuff secret.
Where's trying to find these algorithms,
these tools,
these ways of thinking and uh,
get them out to people who will take them.
Uh,
on that vein,
I will say that we have a very good
relationships with many of the leading AI
teams. Uh, Google invited me
to do a talk recently, um,
but, uh, we have much less
good relationships with
a Russian Chinese teams.
I don't speak very much Russian
nor Mandarin. Um, but, uh, uh,
so, so good relationships
I think help, uh,
propagate these ideas when you get them.
But by and large,
we don't see it as our prerogative
to go around, you know,
poking our noses into the capabilities
work that other teams are doing, uh,
and shake a stick at them.
Something.
How do you expect the economics of
artificial intelligence development to
effects its safety? Would you prefer
one company to develop AI or many?
Um, so I think that, uh, you know,
I sometimes say about the AI, the Ai
alignment problem that, uh, in order to,
in order to handle AI
alignment well, uh, we need,
uh, so it's much harder to handle AI
alignment if you're in an arms race.
Clearly many things are harder in
an arms race and safety, keeping,
keeping safety concerns and not cutting
corners are especially difficult than an
arms race. Uh, so in order to deal well
with, uh, with general intelligence,
a humanity needs to, uh, uh, you know,
exercise restraint and caution in the
face of large economic incentives, uh,
while handling a gigantic
moral hazard, uh, uh,
of the form where you have a small group
of people who have the ability to, uh,
affect what happens in human society.
On a, on a massive scale, uh, seem to,
you need to resist economic incentives
while dealing with a gigantic moral
hazard, uh, while writing code
that works well on the first try.
Uh, and this is this, this does
not bode well for team human. Uh,
those, those three types of tasks are
not things that humans are unowned,
uh, for being great at. Right.
One of the reasons that I think it's
important to work hard on this now is just
for once I'd like to see humans sort
of go prepared into one of these,
one of these giant technological
shifts. We'll see. Uh,
so how old economics, uh,
affect the safety? Uh,
you know, I think, I think the
economics are definitely making AI.
I go faster these days. We
have talent, we have, uh,
money pouring into the field and that's
going to cause things to speed up.
And what I prefer one company
or many to develop AI. Um,
I think this is less a question of
preference and more a question of how the
world looks. A, there's
lots of debate in our, uh,
in our circles of, of people, uh,
doing this sort of research
about whether or not, uh,
the development of Ai looks more like,
um,
the development of a single software
project or the development of like an open
source community, right? Where, uh,
if AI is sort of like the
open source community,
if it's like a broad base of things that
was worked on by a lot of people, uh,
then it's sort of sort of weird to ask
what if one group creates it and write it
sort of this ecosystem that's growing.
Uh,
and it's sort of hard to
imagine one group, uh,
under control of the AI or something.
Whereas if AI is more
like a search engine, uh,
then even when you have lots of
different groups trying to make the, uh,
search engine, uh, you're gonna have,
uh, empirically in the past, uh,
you have sort of monopoly tendencies
where it's not that Google was the only
team working on search engines,
but Google sure captured the
search engine market, right?
Like there was, uh, uh, there was
Yahoo, there was that fish thing.
Who remembers what it is anymore?
Uh, uh, and yeah,
and,
um,
uh, sort of control of search engines
like development of search engines with
something where uh,
uh,
tools didn't easily transfer when
someone made Google a little better.
It took a while before he got
Yahoo, got a little better. Uh,
and uh,
and the,
the economics were pushing
the direction of monopoly.
And in that case it's sort of hard to
imagine the world ending up with an open
source Google, right. Uh, like there's
a lot of things Google's doing,
they would just be real hard for an
open source community to navigate. Um,
so I think the question of whether or not
we're going to see AI that's sort of a
broadly distributed or, uh, very, very
locally controlled is a question of like,
which type of softwares it,
is it more like this monolithic
type search engine type thing where,
where you're,
you're building it and it's
hard to transmit specific
components to other teams?
Or is it gonna be more like this open
source thing where it's a big ecosystem
and it's hard to even central
area if you wanted to, uh,
my bet as to which world we're in. Is
that just more like the centralized world,
uh, as to which world I'd like to
be in? Um, I dunno. I, that's not,
that's not really how I model worlds.
Alright.
I'll just deal with what's ever wanted.
It turns out we live in
what strategy and tactics
for AI risk mitigation.
Would you recommend the Googlers
who share your views on the risk?
If you are a random Google engineer,
would you focus entirely on donations to
Miri, try internal cross team advocacy,
try to join deep mind or something else
entirely? Um, you know,
one thing that I would do
if you're interested in this
work is I'd reach out to
Chris Olah. I hope he doesn't
mind me saying this, uh,
basic Google or he wrote the,
uh,
he was a coauthor on the concrete
problems paper. Uh, and uh, yeah,
if you're interested in it,
look them up, email them. Uh,
there's probably interesting
stuff you can do,
especially if you're already a brain,
um,
in terms of how one causes
more risk mitigation.
MMM.
You know, it's, it's hard to say,
sort of depends on the person. Uh,
I think,
you know,
20 percenting on a interesting AI safety
stuff is probably a pretty good time.
Um, and I'd say you're always welcome to
get in touch if you have more specific
questions that we had a
link up earlier, but, uh,
it's contact@intelligence.org
very hard to remember.
Uh,
and
yeah, I think it, I think it
depends on a situational basis,
but more eyes on the problem, more
people solving the problems, uh,
is one of the key things I'd encourage
when you were talking about, uh,
the problems of,
um,
the analogy with natural selection and
the contextual changes that creatures
might or might not go through in
natural selection being pretty small.
Um, it occurred to me that, uh,
humans are very different
from cave salamanders,
not just because they're far more
intelligent than cave salamanders,
but because they've been dealing with
far more contextual changes for the past
20,000 generations than cave salamanders.
Perhaps I've been sitting in a cave.
Um, so, uh, you know,
the changing social circumstances and
the changing weather and the changing
Savannah conditions and all the rest
of probably programmed into have forced
natural selection to program into us an
ability to deal with those conceptual
changes that the cave salamander,
it doesn't have.
Would it be useful to do something similar
in creating the genetic algorithms or
the hill climbing algorithms that would,
uh,
get us closer to AI,
by programming and this ability to this,
this requirement and the simulation that
there's a continuous changing in the
contextual elements necessary to
get to that objective function.
Uh, so, uh, I'll caveat first bat. Uh,
I'm,
uh,
I'd want to push in the direction of
sort of more transparent algorithms and
less, less brute force hill
climbing algorithms, uh, uh,
given the opportunity to do so. Uh,
but I do think it's very useful to,
uh, train the system under many
contexts changes. Uh, so, you know,
you shouldn't, I think it would be
foolish to test the system quite a bit,
and then for the first time,
uh,
that you give it a lot more resources than
I've ever had in test environment. Uh,
you put it like out in the world, uh,
to do whatever. Right? That would be,
there'll be sort of
reckless. Uh, so one of the,
one of the things that happens when it
moves from the test environment to the
real world is that the space
of the world's modeling
becomes quite a bit larger.
I, it goes from your lab to
the entire universe. Uh, so
this is a pretty big shift.
Uh, I mean, you might be able to
mitigate this in some ways. And then, uh,
in terms of available resources, if it
starts thinking about things like, uh,
acquiring computation resources,
which you might not want to
design a system that does that,
but it starts thinking about things like
acquiring computational resources. Uh,
then once it leaves the
lab, it sort of has, uh, uh,
far more resources at his disposal and
it did in the lab. Uh, potentially.
And if the,
if,
if the first time that you're testing
its ability to handle dramatic changes in
what the world looks like
and what resources it has
available is deployment, uh,
you're probably gonna
have a bad time. Uh, so I,
I am very pro, uh, testing context
changes as well as you can.
One of the things in the lab,
I will also say that I think
this is not alone sufficient. Um,
if you imagine a,
if you imagine a human on a planet,
a very slow aliens,
uh,
or the very slow aliens are cubs in the
human to like go through a series of
tests before they released
human into the world,
it's pretty plausible
that the human can tell
which one's the final test
environment. Maybe not, but maybe, uh,
and to some extent, uh,
you might want, you know,
if aliens like put up like
some canvases that they paint,
like backdrops on and that they think,
you can't tell,
they think you might think it's
the real world, right? Like, uh,
you've either got to be really, really
sure that you've tested this system, uh,
in context changes where it believes
this is the last context change, uh,
or you've got to have reasons beyond,
uh,
your trial and error and your
tests to expect that, uh,
after the final context change that
it will continue to act as intended.
And I'd sort of suggest both,
when you're dealing with things
that have the ability to transform a
civilization, uh, you should
not be trying to skimp on,
uh, on your safety precautions. So I would
say both test the hell out of it, uh,
especially under context changes and
have additional reasons to believe it's
going to work. Thank you all
for attending and thanks, Nate.
We're talking to Google.
[inaudible].